medical help is on its way to india as
the country
has set a global record for new
infections
for the fifth straight day the european
union and united states are sending
equipment like
ventilators and raw materials needed for
vaccines on the ground
the situation is critical hospital beds
are scarce
morgues are full and the oxygen that is
needed to save people's lives
is in short supply
grief outside hospitals in delhi
disinfecting the dead the fear of
infection remains
even when life has passed
makeshift cremation sites like these are
springing up to deal with a rising death
toll
because crematoriums and cemeteries
cannot cope
relatives feel helpless as the
coronavirus tears through the capital
i have money i have everything but i
can't save my sister
because no bed nothing nothing like that
no gas
no oxygen no bed where we can do where
we can go
as overwhelmed hospitals have run out of
oxygen and intensive care beds
india's prime minister urged patience
and caution
i'm speaking to you on this radio show
at a time when corona is testing our
patience
and our capacity to bear pain
many of our loved ones have left us too
soon
at this moment in order to win this
battle
we must listen to scientists
for several days running the indian
government has reported more than
three hundred thousand new infections
doctors worry the recent surge has been
fueled by a new variant
this one composed of two other more
infectious and vaccine resistant
versions of the virus
health experts fear the result could be
a virus that's faster spreading
and less controllable
several countries have offered help
india's air force collected oxygen
imports from singapore
on the weekend
and the us and the eu are planning to
send aid
eu president ursula fonda lyon says the
block is pooling resources
to respond to india's request for
assistance
but for the sick queuing outside full
hospitals and delhi
these supplies can't come fast enough
and we're going over to daily now where
dw correspondent nimisha jaiswal
is standing by hi nimisha so how quickly
is
international help coming in
well christine india put out an appeal
for international help late last week
and the response has been significant
already there has been support from
singapore that has been flown in
more is expected for the through the
course of this week the uae
saudi arabia even pakistan and china
have come
come in with offers of support we also
have the eu
germany has made a statement that it
will ensure that any
bottlenecks in the supply chain for
vaccine manufacturing are resolved
quickly
because india's supply actually impacts
the global supply
of vaccines as well the u.s invited
criticism over the last couple of weeks
for
restricting the supply of raw materials
that have been crucial for production
in india saying that it actually
requires them for domestic production
but now both president joe biden and
vice president kamla harris have made
statements
that the us will stand by india and also
expedite the production the the delivery
of these raw materials
much like india by the us during its
surge in cases
yeah and and and the coronavirus cases
um have hit a global record peak
uh for a fifth straight day the number
is 353 000. i'll just point out that
that's well over
three hundred thousand more cases than
the next highest country
but even then nimisha it's being said
that the government is under reporting
the number of cases and debts
but christine most of the evidence
around this is still
anecdotal but it is definitely a concern
now already
local journalists have put out reports
saying that the covet waterfall
cremations they're seeing in their towns
and cities
are far above the reported numbers one
major international newspaper reported
that the numbers may be 10 times as high
as the death toll india is reporting
in addition india's positivity rate is
very high which also means that the
prevalence of the disease is very high
in the national capital it's above 30
percent but all of this comes at a time
when the indian government asked twitter
to take down tweets
critical of its handling of the pandemic
so a free flow of information
may be hard to expect uh
india is said to be launching a larger
rollout of its vaccination campaign
that's later this week
uh will vaccines be quickly available
for everybody
this larger rule out of vaccines
christine is for everybody above the age
of 18 so this is going to be a massive
demand
already some steps have been taken to
increase output
the approval of other foreign vaccines
has been ramped up
already russia sputnik has been approved
in addition the government has made
advance payments to major manufacturers
in india
especially those of the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
however there are concerns about a high
price point for these vaccines given
that the states
and private hospitals will now have to
buy these vaccines
at a higher price from manufacturers and
this may actually
affect and impact the the access that
many of india's poor may have to these
vaccinations
however also important to note that half
the vaccine has been given out
will be given out by the central
government for free
all right that's nimisha jaiswal
reporting for us from daily
thank you nimisha and for more i am
joined now
by dr anant ban a researcher in
bioethics and global health policy
in bhopal india good to have you on the
program doctor just last month
the health minister said that india was
in the quote end game of the pandemic
today
the country is hitting global records in
infections what's gone wrong in your
view you recently tweeted that
new variants and mutations were not the
cause
yeah thank you for having me so when i
did when i put in that tweet what i
meant was that of course
variants and mutations could be a driver
in many ways but what one has to
recognize is that the fundamental reason
we might be seeing an increase is that
perhaps we took it easy too soon and
this virus has taught us globally
that you know there is always a chance
of a resurgence in
infections and we need to be extra
cautious and ensure that we are
following public health precautions and
that sometimes i felt
was not being adhered to and the public
health uh messaging was probably getting
relaxed
and the policy makers were not taking
this too seriously so there were mass
congregations happening election rallies
happening and
just a lack of adherence to um you know
the corona norms which could have been a
major driver
dr ban as we've been reporting corona
virus cases have hit
a global record peak for the fifth day
353
000 and and i just want to point out
that that's well over 300 000
more cases than the next highest country
but even then it's being said that the
government is
under reporting the number of cases and
debts
yeah there have been a lot of concerns
uh raised around the fact that
not adequate and correct tabulation of
both cases and debts is happening
in uh in the current situation and that
is being
validated by reports from anywhere from
cremation grounds to
mortuaries etc their official data seems
to be much lesser
now this could also be a vestige of
the fact that even historically before
the pandemic
not all deaths in india were correctly
being tabulated
and and that obviously is being
reinforced now
but it's extremely important for us to
know what the correct data is and that
can help drive the policy
response so hopefully we'll do a better
job of tabulating uh the true impact of
and the international health that's
coming in dr bun is it going to be
enough to reverse the curve now
well one hopes it will significantly
contribute india has been very kind uh
to the global community over the last
year or more
in terms of sharing its expertise its
vaccines etc and i think
as we have learned from the pandemic
over the over the past many months we
are all
in this together and this is a time for
global solidarity
india is unfortunately facing the brunt
at this period of time
but we are all protected by helping each
other out and
this time india certainly needs the help
of all the help it can
all right that's dr anant ban bio ethics
and global health expert talking to us
from bhopal india thank you dr bun
and here's a look at some other
developments in the pandemic bangkok has
extended its coronavirus restrictions as
it deals with a new outbreak parks gyms
some cinemas and decay centers have been
ordered to shut
hong kong and singapore have confirmed
they're launching a travel
bubble in may travelers will be allowed
to fly between the cities without going
into quarantine once they meet strict
conditions
and israel's health ministry says it's
examining whether cases of heart
inflammation
are linked to the biontech pfizer
vaccine
most were reported in men under the age
of 30.
you